sneako met Charlie who's Charlie most
critical the guy the white dude
my boy come up
come up here
who did that
you see what's happening in the
background dude
you all know he ain't gonna say anything
to my face
[Music]
is that Charlie
who did that who the [__] did that that
is so good that is so good I would pay I
would pay to have a whole episodes of
different things that happened I yo who
did that uh it's a channel called me
King God damn
no let's keep watching thank you yo baby
baby
can you and your man take this into the
other room please I I can't hear myself
think with all that love making you
doing yeah fine whatever no problem no
problem sneaky no it's it's Nico
oh that's good [__]
who the [__] did that
and you have the angel of death it's so
wild if you look at the wakes they got
cobwebs on them
yeah basically saying there's no it's
never lifted they even got Tate's
picture in the background
they really did a good job representing
his room
[Music]
yo chat Charlie is at my door
what should I say to him
what do you want you little soy boy
loser nice
what the hell is that
[Music]
chat
Charlie's at my he's at my bedroom door
[Music]
what do I do
hey
the legs the legs
the legs through the legs
[Music]
who did that
bro they gave this man Ethiopian legs
actually it's wild that's [__] up this
is private property
you you better leave that's a chastity
belt
[__]
[Music]
is not leaving
okay all right fine
Sorry Charlie but you asked for this
Chatham out of ammo I gotta find another
clip it's cold
a magazine
laughs
hey this is good this is Mama look at
the angel at death you better get out of
here
[Music]
Charlie I'm actually a huge fan I just I
watch your stuff all the time
just let me turn off my stream and
maybe we can talk this over okay
[Music]
let go with me
Andrew Tate wept
laughs
there's nothing that gets me more hard
than my favorite movie Paddington too
this movie is like if you combined
[Laughter]
they're literally nailed his Cadence
bell delphine's tiny little tits and uh
something else that's good I don't know
anyway that's it for today see ya yo
that's good they killed it they killed
it yo they killed that [__] yo and you
know what's so funny so I remember this
clip I saw a while back
but before Nico became like a tate
Fanboy basically you know you know Daddy
takes son yeah um there's a there's a
clip of him reacting to uh Tate watches
really if I was him I'd hate us I hate
you of course he does of course he does
don't get mad at the dude he's fat he's
short he's clearly lonely he's wearing
[__] baggy ass shorts all right now
they're going a little too like come on
bro fat sure all right you don't need to
why are you you shouldn't be like
physically talking about another man on
that line you fat lying piece of [__] I
would beat the the American he looks
[__] amazed dress is American I'm in
my tailored ten thousand dollar suits
without a geeky hat on I haven't got a
pedo mustache I got all the women I got
money he just said I paid ten thousand
dollars why do you spend ten thousand
dollars on suits
it's a suit it looks the same all the
time it's a [__] black jacket black
pants and a top you don't need to spend
10 bands on that you you spend 10 bands
on it so you could say in a podcast that
it costs 10 bands but just dress well
I got the Bugatti I got the jet it's
true but no of course he hates us of
course but it's just an amazing I got a
jet I gotta see this one I don't know
man like these self-help dudes are just
a little are too full of themselves like
why are you yelling about your jet on a
podcast
how long ago was that a year
this is a year
people can switch people can flip
there's something something my man is
like pancakes he's lack of
self-awareness to somebody like that
it's actually almost an impressive lack
of self-awareness for someone like that
to look at someone like me who's as
accomplished as I am with every genetic
gift all right bro like as accomplished
I am with the genetic Gifts of a man and
the physical superiority of my body
why are you like bro you're what are you
you're wearing a shiny [__] bomber
gold jacket with open and sunglasses on
you look like a video game character you
look like what a 12 year old would pick
as his GTA character don't all right
there's self-help for men and then
there's also just jerking yourself off
to other men because right now you're
like all right Anakin sneak Walker like
[__] you said mannequin sneak Locker
yeah
that's actually right no but you flip on
the dark side and they move with Nico
along that's crazy
[Music]
today
[Applause]
if you look at pictures of him now he's
wearing the same type of shirts he's
literally wearing Shades indoors during
interviews so he's literally copied
verbatim takes whole Playbook yeah you
know for someone who calls himself calls
everyone else a bot it's crazy how he
became a tape bot himself he became what
you hate
and you hate a tape bro button up your
[__] jacket feet but the thing that
happened is that uh he didn't become
tape he did no he became the image sure
because he's not doing what the thing is
this I actually believe Tate does
everything that he says he does
that's the difference
I believe he does and he moves exactly
how he he says he moved it's not the
fact that oh I got respect for that but
I got more respect for that than for
emulators that emulates that they
emulate the fact that they move like him
do what they don't speak or don't do
what they does snico doesn't doesn't
have the training doesn't have nothing
that they're emulating that same thing
with other people like that they're
doing that at least eight
is doing what he says he does
good or bad
consistent he's consistent in what he
says probably no because sometimes it's
a character sometimes it's not I'm not
I'm just joking no you're not you know
what I mean I don't think he's gonna
what I mean by what I mean by that he's
trying to play a game where you go you
always say that he's trying to play game
and when he said it's consistent it's
because it benefits him and when he says
when he's saying it's a game it's
because it benefits him when it's not
but at the end of the day I think he
really moves like that homie uses the
the the game and character card when
he's in trouble you understand what I'm
saying but other than that he I think he
actually lives like that the girls or
this the that the the Mansion the he
lives like that most of the other dudes
don't yeah I guess you're saying a lot
of the guys in the Ripple just
cosplaying Lee cosplaying the out here
players but they married and they're not
getting nothing on this side even though
they say like options yeah you shouldn't
do this you shouldn't do that and your
whole life is this your whole wife is
that or you shouldn't date uh girls that
are like the girls that are in the
industries and stuff like that and then
you do and they don't where they doesn't
really give a [__] he's like I disagree
I disagree he claims the whole Muslim
thing meanwhile he owns casinos and
still running the sex work sex web stuff
like he's also fake about a lot of his
stuff too I don't I don't buy that it's
the amount of fake yeah
these guys like women in the chat
there's like maybe six of you here do
you think that these guys are gonna be
fun to date I guess I don't know them
and I'm judging it off with two minutes
of the podcast where they're defending
themselves being called in cells I guess
it'd be fun like because like this I
think this guy on the left is a fighter
stuff like that so like a woman will
enjoy that but based on this so far do
you think that they're getting like the
Charming personality that women want to
be Charmed that's that's actually takes
precedent over the rest of the
superficial stuff that men always talk
about in this podcast women want to have
a good time now you listen to them today
and he's the exact opposite it's just an
interesting little look into it you know
what it makes me think of what it's like
when you know a girl and then a pimp
roll through and then you don't know her
anymore
sneako just got pimped yeah yeah say
that whole thing [__]
I'll be in my car you join me one
two
crazy but anyways let us know what you
guys think in the comments below
like the champagne that's Nico yeah